Where do you see with this predictive
history where who's going to be battling
who? Uh when does it begin? Has it
already begun? And who wins?
>> Yeah. Yeah. No, I I would say we've been
in World War II ever since 2020 20 2022
when Russia invaded Ukraine. Uh because
that was a proxy war really between the
United States and Russia, right? Because
even though it was Ukrainians who were
fighting on the battlefield, it was NATO
intelligence, NATO targeting, NATO
special forces, NATO financing, NATO
weaponry. was it was everything that
NATO had except except it's its ground
forces. Um so I would say we've been at
war ever since 2022 but definitely this
year things will ramp up and uh the
conflict will go global. Okay. So let's
look at certain uh key hot spots right
so Ukraine will will will maintain will
continue to be uh one of the major flash
points of the world because e the
Europeans will not give up project
Ukraine. You cannot afford to give up
project Ukraine because it will go
bankrupt otherwise. So you have spe you
have European volunteers, European
special forces going into Ukraine to
show up the front lines because it
seemed as though Ukraine front lines
will collapse at any moment. Okay. And
uh they will continue to antagonize
Russia and Putin. You know, there was
this um silly attack against Putin's
residents trying to assassinate him a
few weeks ago which really anger Putin
and Putin basically said, "Forget this.
No more negotiations. You guys are
hopeless. This is all hopeless. Let's
just finish this on the battlefield.
Okay. So, I think Russia has basically
has basically decided that no, we can
only decide this on the battlefield. So,
this war in Ukraine will continue to
escalate. Um the Europeans will move
towards conscription, false
conscription, especially Germany. So, so
you will see the remilitarization of
Germany which will antagonize uh the
other European nations. Um Trump will
continue to piss off the Europeans. Um
Trump will continue to side with the
Russians against the Europeans because
Trump in our in his heart really really
hates uh the Europeans. So that's the
European Russia front. Okay. Um in the
Americas, Trump will continue to exert
dominance over the Western Hemisphere.
The reason why is that in April he
visits he visits Beijing and that's and
this is a very key meeting for Trump. In
fact, I believe that President Trump and
President C are scheduled to meet four
times this year and the first will be
April and they have to work out a grand
bargain. Okay. So, the conflict right
now is that United States needs China to
continue to to purchase US dollars
because the US dollars is this great
Ponzi scheme and if China switch to gold
or tries to internationalize the UN,
this could cause a Ponzi scheme
collapse. Um but at the same time, China
still needs access to markets and the
great fear is that the United States
uses its navy to embargo China. Um which
is what we're seeing in Venezuela today.
Okay? So they need to work out a grand
bargain. And so what Trump needs to show
presidency is that I control the Western
Hemisphere. I control Mexico. I control
Venezuela. I control Brazil. I control
Canada. I I control Greenland. That's
why there's there's all these
provocations against Greenland at this
at this time. And eventually you have
provocations against Canada as well
because the reason why is that China
relies on the western hemisphere for
access to uh silver, lithium and copper
as well as other rare earth minerals
which fuels China's AI growth uh its EV
industry, its batteries, its solar
panels. So its entire high-tech industry
relies on these commodities from the
Western Hemisphere. So if Trump decides
to choke off China, then China's um
hijack industry would suffer a great
deal. And so I think eventually uh China
and United States will come to a grand
bargain where um and so for example look
at Venezuela where Trump has said that
American companies will go and modernize
the Venezuela oil industry. And guess
what? these American companies, Exom
Mobile, they're not going to do that
because they have to invest tens of
billions of dollars and there's great
risk involved because Trump is volatile,
right? But
>> the Chinese will the Chinese will go and
invest all this money and modernize the
oil industry so that they can extract
this oil to feed their own economy.
China relies um on threequarters of his
oil from overseas. Half it half of of
its oil supply comes from the Middle
East. So if there's a war in Iran, then
China's kind of screwed, right? So I
think the grand bargain will be reached
between China and the United States. The
problem though is Japan because as China
becomes closer to the United States,
Japan fears the rise of China, right?
And the great issue is Taiwan. So so
both China and Japan rely on oil imports
from the Middle East. And so they have
to go through the straight of Malaa.
That's that that's a main trade route.
And so whoever controls Taiwan can
choose to embargo the other nation. So,
you know, the Japanese Prime Minister
Takachi has said that Taiwan is of a of
vital strategic interest to Japan, and
she's correct. But that caused a huge
political ferror in China, and China
right now wants it wants to blockade,
embargo Japan, deny Japan rare earth
minerals. So, this year, we're going to
see this massive conflict arise between
Japan and China because there's no way
there's no there's no way around it.
These are both nations that are heavily
dependent on trade and they will get in
into each other's way and so and this
conflict benefits United States because
both China and United States are heavy
uh buyers of US treasuries right so
Trump more weapons to uh to Japan so so
that's that's a play but but you'll see
increased hostility between China and
Japan even as relations between China
and United States improve
you'll see increased conflict between
Russia and United States in the oceans
because right now the United States is
engaged in piracy, right? United States
is going around and and and stealing
these oil tankers from Russia and from
China and there was an incident where
Bella 1 what one of these shadow lead
tankers it was trying to be it was it
was being boarded by the US Coast Guard
and the and the Russians intervene. So
you'll see more of these incidents
>> and in fact Russia will eventually
figure out that even though it cannot
defeat um United States in the oceans,
it has to challenge the United States in
the oceans. So it has to build up a blue
water navy and China will probably
finance this blue water navy in order to
pro protect its own trade interest. So
the United States can produce one ship
for every 250 ships that China produces.
Okay. So China has this tremendous ship
building capacity and if United States
engages in this n in this warfare
against Russia in the seas is eventually
a war of attrition will will happen and
the United States Navy will will face
rapid decline. Okay. So I I see how this
this this is how I see the global
landscape turning out. The same time
United States you have civil war emerge.
You have
>> civil war emerge probably in Europe as
well. You have economic collapse
everywhere. and then these nations won't
be forced to scramble for resources and
to protect trade access. So 2026 is when
things accelerate. Um Trump will
continue to be an antagonistic. He'll
continue to um piss everyone off, the
Europeans,
um the the American left. Um and um
yeah, I mean we're we're headed for a
very stormy um um for for a very stormy
time, a very turbulent time in our
history. But but this is a new normal.
Uh 2027 2027 will be even worse because
that that's why I think that the United
States will actually launch invasion of
Iran. So uh 2026 will be will be a great
conflict between China and America as
they try to reconcile the differences.
And once you reconcile the differences,
this will open up uh uh Iran for
invasion because great fear is that the
United States invades Iran. At this
point, Russia and China will support
Iran and and there's a great possibility
that the United States will lose this
war. Um there's no way that Russia will
abandon uh Iran, but China can be
negotiated away from uh from Iran. And
that's Trump's game plan before he
launches a full-scale invasion of Iran.
Look, look, it's already been settled.
There's already an agreement that the
United States will go and invade Iran
because if the United States wants to
maintain its imperial hijgemony, it
needs to control trade access. It needs
to control Iran. Um because once it
controls Iran, then China is blockaded.
The Bel and Road initiative is dead and
and now the entire Russian southern
flank, okay, the southern bottom of
Russia is open up is opened up and and
Russia could be outflanked. So um Iran
is crucial to the maintenance of
American hijgemony. The question that
the question now is when will this
happen and how will this happen? So I
think it will happen next year not this
year. Um and it need and Trump needs to
create this grand bargain with China
before he moves ahead. um Iran will also
be a major flash point in 2026 because
um right now these protests in Iran and
we know exactly what's going to happen
because we've seen this playbook before
in Libya and Syria. What's going to
happen is that Mossad is going to create
these insurgent groups in Iran on the
borderlands. They'll be protected by air
strikes and be financed by um by the
CIA. uh you have these Mossad agents um
leading these groups and you'll have
slowly economic blockade of Iran. Uh you
have sabotage, infiltration in Iran.
You're you're going to hear a lot about
Iran because the Americans, the
Israelis, they'll try to create this in
this narrative that any day now the
Mullas will flee to Moscow. Any day now,
the regime will collapse. Any day now,
the military will launch a coup d'eta
against Iran. any day now these Iranian
people will rise up and referral the
regime and look the reality is that Iran
is under tremendous pressure and so
you'll have this infiltration you have
these insurgent groups you'll have
warfare going uh on in Iran so you
you'll hear a lot about Iran in 2026
>> what are the chances none of this
happens and we just go on and live our
merry lives [laughter]
and we just don't see a big world war
again what are the chances is do you
think?
>> Yeah, I think we've crossed the Rubicon.
I I I think we are in a new normal. Um I
think it's very hard to go back to 2020.
Like I I know that a lot of people um
believe that, you know, in November the
Democrats will win the midterms and
somehow we'll go back to normal. But but
think about who the Democrats will run
in November. They'll probably run a lot
of blue dogs, right? These uh candidates
from the national security apparatus.
And what do they want? They want Trump
to accelerate these wars overseas. They
want Trump to attack Iran. They want
Trump to um antagonize Russia, right?
So, I I I I think we've crossed the
Rubicon, I I I think we are in a break
world.
>> But it sounds like with what you're with
the picture you're painting with this
world war is that it's Russia versus
Europe, it's Japan versus China, it's
Israel versus Iran. Um but the United
States is doing deals. It sounds like
like maybe to try to stay I mean besides
a naval blockade style war it sounds
like the US is I mean until the US has
to go and invade Iran on behalf of
Israel cuz probably what'll lead up to
that is Israel is going to have to
attack Iran be in a war with Iran.
Israel is going to have to start losing
that war in order for the United States
to rush in and help them out. If if
Israel's winning that war the US won't
do that. So Israel would have to start
losing that war.
>> I think You'll also you'll also see a
lot of false flags in 2026, right? So
these attacks against American interests
in Iraq uh in Syria
and basically and also possibly on the
homeland as well. So
>> yeah.
>> Yeah. I mean, yeah, I I I think you're
right. But I would also add in the
possibility of false flags as as well.
>> False flags. Okay.
>> And that Yeah. And that would piss off
everybody and then we'd say go to war.
That's it. Just like 911.
>> Yeah. So, so,
>> so other than the other than the US
going into Iran, it looks it sounds like
you're saying the US is going to try to
not go to war with Russia. I mean, Trump
doesn't seem to want that. Um, I don't
think we want war with China. And
actually, I don't think China wants war
with anybody. I mean, I feel like China
doesn't want to get involved at all.
>> That's right.
>> Maybe financing, but that's it.
>> That's right. You're exactly right. Um
yes, China will engage in development um
in in financing, but that's it. It will
not send in troops anywhere. Um
>> look, I mean, if you read the national
security strategy, right, um which is
Trump's framework for the for um uh the
empire for the next um 10 years, a lot
of people believe that uh the national
security strategy, it's about creating
spheres of influence, right? right? A
multipolar world where Russia controls
Europe, China controls East Asia, and
United States stay stays in the Western
Hemisphere. If you actually read the
national security strategy, it doesn't
say that. It doesn't say that United
States will retreat back in the Western
Hemisphere. What it does say is that the
United States will maintain its empire
through a new strategy before it
maintain its empire through these
multilateral organizations like the
United Nations. And now what the
national what the strategy is to aband
the illusion of these liberal
multilateral organizations just leave
the United Nations which is what the
United States has done and focus on pure
power politics and it will use divide
and rule in order to maintain control
over the world. So it will not leave
East Asia but it will promote Japan as
its proxy in the war against China.
Okay. Um, it's not going to leave Euro,
but it's it's but it's going to
overthrow these liberal
uh European regimes and instead champion
nations like Austria, Hungary, and
Poland, which are more aligned with
Trump values. Um, and it's going to
fight in Africa for influence and
economic dominance against China. It it
United States does not plant a seed
anywhere. The United States will not
retreat from anywhere, but it's going to
change the rules of the game to meet the
new reality of the American empire.
Before Americans were shy about empire,
before Americans insist on the
rules-based liberal international order,
and Trump's like, "Screw that. We're an
empire. Might is right. Let's just be an
empire."
>> Where is the safest place in the world
to be during all of this, would you say?
>> You know what? I have three kids. I'm
trying to figure out figure out the same
thing. Okay. [laughter]
Um, so look look I've been thinking
about this for a long time. The problem
is that wherever place you pick everyone
goes to, right? So like look, everyone
believes that New Zealand will be safe.
But if everyone's going to New Zealand,
how safe is that? Right? If Peter Theo
is building a bunker in New Zealand and
all this money is being is is flowing to
New Zealand, um, that's that's going to
create a lot of conflict and chaos as
well. The reality is that uh natives
don't like immigrants. Uh you know, so
you know, you go to Europe and you have
all these immigrants that are and the
natives hate that and and it'll probably
create a race war in Britain. Um New
Zealand is not is right now under a lot
of strain. Um you know, the natives are
being priced out of the property market.
Um so I wouldn't say it's about
geography. I would say it's more about
mindset. I think in this new world, you
have to give up this materialist mindset
where you know what, I'm I'm going to
make a million dollars, retire, buy
myself a yacht, and enjoy the world. You
have to focus on your own spiritual and
philosophical development. You have to
like learn things. You have to watch the
news. You have to be resilient. You have
to think about what what matters in
life. Um what what what you have to
recognize is that ultimately this world
can go to chaos. But guess what? Most of
you most of human history has been
chaos. But what matters to me is my uh
family, my friends, my children, my
community. If you focus on that, you
will get past all this chaos. This chaos
will not affect you if you're able to
build a strong community and you're all
focused on all on spiritual personal
fulfillment. Um I guarantee you you'll
live a very happy life if if you do
that. But if you're insistent on like,
you know, like I have $10 million in the
bank, so should I go investing in gold
and silver, should I move to Israel or
New Zealand or Chile, uh you you know
you you'll drive yourself insane because
um this world is going to go crazy. And
if you if you believe that you can you
have $10 million, you can maintain this
wealth um during this all this chaos,
you're you'll just go insane. You have
you have to give up the the idea that
wealth matters in this world. what
matters at the end of at the end of the
day is mindset, resilience, uh
spirituality.
>> Well, uh, Professor Xiang, thank you so
much for being here, um, and and sharing
with us your knowledge and the
predictive history, the game theory.
It's, uh, uh, it is a scary time that
we're marching into, but I agree with
you. You know, people live in war torn
areas. My mother grew up in one. People
survive. people if you focus on the
right things um you can get through it
and uh and and that is so I like what
you say there at the end that is that is
what we should be focusing on realigning
our values and what we what we what we
value what we want to hold on to so um
the YouTube channel is predictive
history I do have the link down below uh
definitely you know more people should
be watching you already have a million
you should have more than that you know
[laughter] soon enough um you're doing
amazing work. Really absolutely love
everything that you're doing. So, thank
you so much and keep it up and thank you
so much for being here with us.
>> No, thanks so much, Kim. It was a
wonderful first wonderful first
conversation. I I I would love to be
back whenever you have time.
>> Would love to have you back. That's for
sure. Thank you. Thank you again.
>> Thank you for watching this clip from
the full Kim Iverson show, which you can
watch Monday through Friday, 5:00 p.m.
Eastern, 2:00 p.m. Pacific at kim
Iversonshow.com.
See you there.